a report by our 8 news now i-team spurs
calls for a federal investigation the
i-team shed light on the lack of medical
care for an elderly veteran and now two
u.s senators are demanding answers the
i-team's vanessa murphy is here with a
follow-up to her exclusive story
denise and brian nevada's two u.s
senators call the va's response
inadequate in their letter to the office
of the inspector general in washington
d.c they're calling for a full
investigation which they say could help
identify any resources or guidance
needed from congress we want to warn you
some of the video is disturbing
how critical is this situation
he is dying u.s senators jackie rosen
and catherine cortez masto are demanding
answers after our report which first
aired on may 23rd this video leaked to
the 8 news now i-team shows an
88-year-old marine corps veteran
collapse inside a v.a medical clinic in
las vegas on june 7 of 2021 we showed
the video to a physician who runs his
own medical office and an attorney with
experience in medical malpractice both
pointed to a lack of urgency in caring
for the veteran tick tock it's seeming
like a long time already the veteran was
later taken to sunrise hospital and
pronounced dead in their letter to the
office of the inspector general in
washington d.c senators rosen and cortez
masto write we cannot allow a tragedy
like this to happen again they also
point to the time frames demonstrated in
our report two minutes for a nurse to
arrive and nearly five minutes to begin
cpr which dr scott glickman called
incomplete because the staff didn't
deliver breaths to the veteran when we
interviewed the head of the va health
care system in southern nevada on april
14 we did not reveal we had the leaked
video do you think care was delayed
hands-on care to this patient
so without getting into the details of
that patient i would have to say no i'd
say we responded accordingly that you
would see in any other
healthcare clinic of that nature after
the v.a learned we had the video a
spokesman sent a lengthy statement
admitting mistakes were made now both
u.s senators say the incident warrants
closer review from an independent entity
it's sad it's it's emotional that
you know somebody you're in a facility
where
you think that you're going to get
medical attention and you think you know
people are going to run to your rescue
and that's just not happening here
a family member says the veterans family
was told he died of a heart attack they
did not know about the video until we
contacted them and an autopsy was not
done so we don't know if the delay in
care contributed to his death you can
find our original full report at eight
newsnow dot com